Oh
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast get Co X BSF expression
system 1 chemically defined platform for
high-level expression of proteins from
insect cells presented by Maya yeshiva
and RD scientists from thermo Fisher
Scientific I'm dr. Susie Valdez of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event we're delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor visit WWF
am before we begin I want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen types of questions into the
drop-down box that appear on the screen
and will answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the ask a question box and let
them know you're having a problem please
join me now in welcoming our presenter
Maya Yahveh
I will now turn the presentation over to
her welcome Maya Thank You Susan
thank you for the introduction hello
everyone I have the pleasure to
introduce to you the newest member of
the XP geckos XP family of the
expression platforms the XP SF
expression system which is the very
first chemically define insuk cell
baculovirus based expression system that
can generate up to three times more
protein compared to the existing into
expression platforms the X CSF
expression system enables greater
consistency across multiple expression
runs only less time due to the improved
baculovirus generation step for the rest
of my presentation I'm gonna start with
a very brief overview of Y what are some
of the advantages of using insect cell
expression system
and then I'm going to go over and more
details on the XPS F system going
through each of the individual
components as well as showing you some
data around the performance of the
complete system as well as fuel case
studies and a specific model proteins
that we have expressed in this system in
sexual expression system has been around
for about 30 years now or maybe even a
little more and it's been a suitable
platform for expression of multimeric
proteins virus-like particle some
sometimes proteins that are simply toxic
to mammalian cells and the recent years
have gained a lot of popularity around
the expression of AAV as well
baculovirus based technologies enable
our large DNA payroll to be transferred
to the cells which makes them a
favorable platform for those large
proteins the proteins expressed in insuk
cells typically have simpler more
homogeneous post-translational
modifications compared to the mammalian
cells which makes them of favourable
proteins for use in structural and
functional studies the insects El
platform generally has a lower cost and
equipment requirements computer to the
mammalian system and last but not the
least the this platform has been a
really popular the last couple of years
by being an established platform for
vaccines and virus therapeutical here I
have few of the latest additions to the
market that have been made in insuk
cells with one of the latest being added
a few years ago it's the full block the
seasonal flu vaccine is made by protein
scientist corporation now personally but
with all those advantages in six L
platforms do have some challenges
associated with them and some
disadvantages that people need to
overcome when using this system one of
the biggest disadvantages being the
presence of eastland and other undefined
components to in the media that
created a lot of walks log variability
which together with the generally lower
yield coming from the insect cell
protein expression systems and the time
that requires for the generation of
baculovirus sometimes makes this
platform a little more tedious to work
with and require more time and the
results might not be that satisfying
what we try to achieve here we took a
system based approach in which we began
with the development of fully chemically
defined media so this was our heart of
the system removed by removing East laid
and removing any other undefined
components we were able to achieve great
consistency right to run together with
the chemistry defined media we added sf9
cells that are adapted in the chemically
defined media and can grow to high
densities we also added a protein
expression enhancer that is a critical
component in protein expression step and
allows for protein expression boost and
achieving at least three times higher
protein Tigers in the last edition as
part of this system based approach was
the addition of a new and improved to
inspection reagent double our shortening
the time from long to protein expression
without this we were able to achieve
more proteins greater consistency in the
shorter time here in the next slide I
have the word what is the XTS F system
consisted of so we currently offer a
starter kit that includes all of the
components but some of those components
are going to be sold individually as
well as part of the starter kit besides
the XPS fcd medium the XPS f9 sells the
XTS spectrum intersection region and the
XPS F in cancer we also added the gh 10
back selves and a p5 back sector
necessary to generate your virus using
the back to back system as well as we
added the optimum media which is used
complexation during the baculovirus
generation step the next couple of
slides I'm going to go over each of the
individual components and show you a
little more details in theater around
the performance of each of them I'm
going to start with a chemically defined
medium as I said this is one of the
biggest improvements of this system this
XPS fcd medium does not containing each
slate or other kind of hydrolysates it's
an edge animal origins free serum and
protein free it is a complete media that
does not require any supplementation
it's one medium that can be used from
the beginning to the end
starting from cell growth through virus
generation going into protein expression
you will need different media's and the
greatest advantage of this media besides
the consistency is that the cells were
able to achieve a really high cell
density of about 20 million as you can
see on the graph on the top right a
typical Eastern edge containing media
can achieve about 12 at most 15 million
in some cases while with the XPS LCD
media we consistently can get a pixel
density of about 20 million as well as
we can get them consistently as you can
see on the bottom graph we track the
doubling times of across 15 passages and
compare them the doubling times of the
XPS fcd medium with three other
suppliers eastery containing media and
you can see the great consistency and
how each passage you can rely on
yourself to be where you expect them to
be compared to some of the fluctuation
that can be seen in the other media's
with continuing the consistency team we
also compare multiple lots of this media
as you can see on the graph on the Left
we have four different lots of media
four different laws of media are showing
a great consistency in growth kinetics
as expected from a chemically defined
media that does not contain anything
that should create lots of variability
as well as we've seen a great
consistency in regard to protein
expression on the right even after 12
months from the manufacturing date so
this media is really stable for over 12
months across multiple locks with this
is going to move to the south the XPS F
cells are derived from a gift credit
lines of wine that has been extensively
adapted into the chemically do XPS F
chemically defined medium those cells
are pretty pretty typical round
morphology as a thin for all the cells
are wise as you can see on the picture
on the right
the typical diameter of those cells is
between 16 point 5 and 16 17 microns
when they are not infected
of course after infection the diameters
were increased significantly as I'll
show this a little later in this
presentation
the typical doubling times are about 24
hours
and though and again those cells are
have been able to grow to really high
densities of about 20 million which
makes a key characteristics and key
differentiation of those cells compared
to some of the other insects all like so
wise in general is that very typical for
those high density cultures we don't
recommend feeding them and passages them
as to all the density so if you can see
on the graph on the right
the typical kinetics growth kinetics of
those cells they're in the early log
phase somewhere between 5 and 10 million
which is our recommendation for faceting
those a very critical recommendation is
to now pass those cells before they
reach 5 million
otherwise you might experience some
lagging and now the optimal performance
of those cells those will have been very
stable over 20 passages you can see on
both graphs in regard to growth on the
right and R in regard to protein
expression on the left we see a very
consistent profiles so with the cells
I'm going to move to the protein explode
to the transaction reagent the XPS item
in s transfection reagent is an improved
lipid based inspection reagent that has
allow us to improve the transaction
protocol and deliver a convenient
protocol that has few important
characteristics and few improvements the
first one being around shorter
complexation time distillation reagent
require only 5 minutes for efficient
complexation it does not require
separate complexation of the GNA and
lipid instead if those can be added
directly in a single tube and then the
one of the main advantages of this
reagent is the fact that it has a lower
cytotoxicity so it does not require any
media changes phosphorous section and we
can also achieve higher tires in shorter
time even though we do provide a trellis
here and based protocol with this
transection reagent as you can see on
the top left right graph we have a
typical titer comparison between is here
and the suspension We strongly recommend
and we're exploring this is the newest
protocol that we have developed a
suspension based format because it
allows for getting a larger volume of
virus shorter times and a better quality
virus that does not need for additional
virus amplification and it eliminates
the need for additional virus
simplification which significance we can
shorter your timelines
we have developed a different scales of
the suspension protocol so you can go
anywhere between four ml of 200 ml of p0
virus depending on your needs and
requirements and get very consistent
tires of about 10 to the nine infectious
virus particles per ml and then here I
can actually show you the the great
improvement by using the suspension you
can shorten your timelines with about
half of the time so with a classical
protocol going from a back meet DNA
going to repeat zero virus of about
achieving is most about three ml and
then the need of at least one or two of
our amplifications before we go to
protein expression can take anywhere
every 12 12 and 20 days with the new and
improved ex DSS protocol going from a
Backman DNA you can get up 200 ml of p0
virus which can be directly using PC and
protein expression and that way you can
save at least half of the time and with
the graph on the right we have compared
the protein expression with virus
generated in the XP SF protocol in the
red bar as well as viruses made the P p1
and p2 virus is made in the classical
protocol on the tube blue bars and you
can see that there is no difference in
the protein tires even with p0 you can
get slightly better titers from the p2
in the classical since with any further
amplification you're introducing an
additional level of messaging effects
which might reduce the viral quality and
the good protein expression for
and with the virus being made in a
shorter time we can move on to the
protein expression step where we added
an additional component that is critical
for the obtaining higher protein tires
the XPS at enhancer is a chemically
defined proprietary formulation protein
booster and which is I think it's one of
the unique addition for the insuk cell
workflow not many suppliers do offer a
similar component to boost protein
expression the critical step or the
critical key characteristic of this
enhancer in that it needs to be added at
a specific time to obtain maximum
results that we have identified at the
optimal time for additional be enhancer
is 18 to 24 hours before infection
because what the enhancer does it stages
the cell to get ready to efficiently
uptake the back row virus and perform
the infections optimally at those higher
densities that we have developed a
protocol arm since those XPS f9 cells
can achieve higher density we took
advantage of that and were able to
perform the infection and are higher
than typically than densities so the
addition of the enhancer was critical
for that then hazards also also
optimized to work primarily with the XPS
fcd medium so it's currently available
as a production kit together with the
media and on the graph on the left you
can see the overall improvement in
protein titers from compared to Lana
classical expression in the SS nine
cells in SF 902 media and s nine cells
where we can achieve about one one and a
half to two point with the xzsf system
without the enhancer and we can get a
pre-crease fold and above
when we add the enhancer and use the
complete X PSS system the graph on the
right is showing some time course while
we were optimizing the precise addition
timing of the enhancer and you can see
that the 18 to 24 hours is truly giving
you the best performance if added
earlier if the virus is that it earlier
or later that might not be the optimal
with this I'm going to move to wrapping
up the system and showing you the two
main protocols just so this is just a
brief overview of the how are the
protocols look like pretty
straightforward we haven't introduced
too many additional steps or anything
that complicates the workflow the back
of virus generation step has one edition
which is slightly different than what is
typically done
we found out that to get the best
performance and the best titers the
cells need to be put in a fresh medium
at first so we see the south of 2.5
million in fresh media then we add the
optimum in the XP sf9
section reagent and back need DNA
complexation five-minute complexation we
add that to the culture and then in
about 3 to 5 days you can obtain a high
tiger p0 virus that can be further using
protein expression and then on the
bottom is a protein expression step in
which we prepare the cells the day
before infection we see them at 5
million ad then cancer right away and
then after 18 to 24 hours we add the
back of your virus and then again in
about two to three three to four days
depending on the specific proteins you
can harvest your proteins and do your
further downstream analysis with this
I'm going to show what to look for in a
typical SPSS protein production step and
infection in after three days post
infection there are few parameters that
are typically observed what we do if the
infection has proceeded efficiently we
have seen typical viable cell densities
of about 48 million viability drop
usually to about 60 to 80 percent and
then sell the amateur increase to 18 to
20 microns and on the graph on the
bottom on the left you can see the
typical a comparison between a
traditional protocol insect cell of
kinetics for instance of protein
expression kinetics as well as the
kinetics seen in the XPS protocol very
comparable viability drop in between
both systems
and a considerable VCD drop and of
course the Exorcist XPS f system has
showing a higher Bible Bible cell
density which reflects of the right
graph which reflects to having more
biomass and getting more protein in the
same volume the next slide I have a
example of what to look for in an
efficient infection on the Left we have
a healthy non-infected as the XPS s
cells there are as I mentioned earlier a
typical Brown 17 microns in diameter
ourselves pretty healthy no not we don't
see any significant counting maybe a
little bit when those go to a really
high density but that does not affect
the protein expression or transfection
and on the right you can see XPS man sex
cells infected with GFP expressing back
of the virus those samples were taken
four days fasting section you can see a
lot of that cells at this point since
this is a little system and the vacuole
virus will ultimately lies the cells but
you can also see few and large cells on
the bottom on the left the enlarged
cells that correspond to the same cells
expressing gfp that have been efficiency
of infected those are some of the key
characteristics to look for when using
the XPS F system and ensure that you
have an optimal protein expression steps
the XPS F system has been optimized to
give you a flexibility and a certain
level of scalability we so far have a
protocol develop from 125 ml shake class
to up to two liters shake class and we
are further working on optimizing the
system into higher scales and moving
into eventually moving into bioreactors
and wave scales with the system you can
also go scale down for any any
applications that might need screen
of multiple clones or require less
volume you can go in 24 Jeep well
Clayton Studios xzsf system and obtain
comparable tires to a flask scale that
can be further transferred to a file
scale if needed if the specific clone is
what you want to scale up with this I'm
concluding the individual steps and I'm
going to move to show you some data
around the complete performance of the
system within an extensive comparison of
the XPS F system with five major
suppliers in success rate media's that
are currently on the market with it an
expensive adaptation of assets nine
selves in each of those media's and then
compare growth and protein expression
for trip to the separate proteins the
top left graph shows the typical growth
profiles as you can see as I mentioned
earlier any of the other media's can
reach at most ten to twelve millions in
this case of peak cell density while the
XPS F exhibits the typically seen
characteristic of about twenty million
of peak cell density which allows for
the higher density infection and protein
production on the bottom we have
compared three different proteins we
have a diffused protein as well as two
inter-cell work those three proteins
represent different expression levels as
you can see from left to right so the
with the first protein we have up to one
gram per liter so very good expression
in a protein with the middle one it's
more of a moderate expressor we get
about 120 mix per liter and then the
last example is another intracellular
protein this harder to express and we
have been able to achieve about 60 MiG's
per liter of that one in the X PSS
system but overall you can see the
average improvement from all those three
proteins is anywhere between three and
four and five folds compared to the
classical expression in
any of those other media so again the
XPS F system can provide besides the
consistency can provide improved titers
as well the lung next to flies I'm going
to move through a specific proteins that
we have expressed in the system and try
to characterize as well the first
example is a secreted protein to reuse a
secreted alkaline phosphatase as a model
which present involved the XP the X PSF
system as well as the SS 900 tool media
using more of a classical lower density
protein expression we were able to
purify the protein using a hist Accura
fication and we did not see any
differences and purity between the two
proteins as well as in regard to
molecular weight the proteins were
absolutely on spot in both systems we
sell the same same quality of a protein
with the advantage of the X PSF system
having more protein and we recently did
some glycan profile even though they
they are not shown in those slides but
we've been able to see a pretty
comparable glycosylation patterns
between the protein express in both
systems as well the next example we
wanted to check the functionality of the
proteins expressed in SPSS system with
tumor necrosis factor-alpha as model
here we express it in both system with
so the expected improvement we actually
so pretty good improvement with those
for that protein of about fourfold and
then we after purifying the protein we
use a TNF alpha tivity athlete I was
measured by luciferase based NF kappa-b
activation cell line so we have a cell
line engineered to produce force if
raised when a TNF alpha is added and
it's activating the t NF kappa-b
that way so after measuring the rooster
freeze producing those cells we can
prepare whether we have a protein with
equal functionality and you can see on
the graph we have a great compared
comparability between the SS 902 media
and the XPS f2 produced the TNF alpha
and the last example that I have is a
very interesting protein so we recently
expressed 7 span g-protein coupled
receptor the calibrated receptor type 2
which was a great model for the
expression of membrane proteins and a
really hard to express protein what we
did with how we approach the expression
with protein we actually first started
with a time course since even though we
generally recommend three to four days
bulk infections harvest time for certain
protein you definitely need to optimize
that in a case of protein like CB 2 we
found out that 48 hours is a better
harvest time point stealth layer time
points the viability of the cells drops
significantly you can see in the bottom
graph both the bottom middle graph the
56 hours we have less than 60% viability
which is starting to reflect if you look
in the graph on the left on the quality
and the the molecules per cell of the CB
2 so after we optimize that we compare
gain the number of molecules of CB to
pour so that we're getting from XPS F
system as well as the SS 9 and when we
compare the total molecules we're
getting from both system we were able to
see about 10 fold improvement in regard
to total protein and we are further
working with a collaborator to purify
and understand more about the
performance of this protein from both
systems
without this I would want to say a big
thank you to the entire team who has
devoted their time on this project we
have pretty extensive team working on
this it's not an easy thing to to get to
the market and there are few people in
R&D that have been tirelessly working on
that sir burns ken Thompson this across
Katy Irvine as well as our business
support and natasha Lukey Henry - and
brick cafi and of course last but not
the least
John's Mota as our RNG director has
always lead us and helped us go through
everything like this so thank you very
much for the attention and I'm happy to
answer any question that it might have
come through my talk Thank You Maya for
that informative presentation and we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now just click on that
ask a question drop-down box located on
the far left of your presentation window
type your questions into the box that
appear on the screen and click that send
button we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for so let's take a look at
our audience number of questions coming
in already
our first question Maya is what are the
normal growth characteristics of xxb sf9
cells Thank You Suzanne great question
so as I show a little early so for those
for the XPS of nine cells we recommend a
pathogen schedule of three or four days
in which one cells are seeded at either
0.5 or 1 million they should reach about
a above 5 million at the time is passing
so if cells are seeded at Point 5 after
4 days they're going to be over 5
million if cells are positive 1 they're
going to be over 5 million in 3 days
so this is this is what what to look for
if anything outside of that if cells are
lagging so it's actually just to add on
that the first one or two passages you
might see a little bit of different
schedule up until the cells are
recovering from the top but past passage
- you should be seeing very consistent
kinetics like this thank you for that
our next question is did you observe any
differences in the quality of virus
production between regular ss9 cells and
XPS f we have not so I don't have the
data here to show as part of this slide
deck but we have computer virus made in
SS 902 and SS 9 cells versus using the
new transfection reagents actually to
some extent the graph that I have here
shows that that when we use the virus
the from p0 in XPS s system versus the
p1 or p2 a virus on the classical system
we don't observe any issues with quality
and for protein expression and thank you
my and how did you measure your virus
leaders that's a great question we we
have actually as part of this system
we're introducing a new virus filtration
method based on flow cytometry which is
a very quick of a very precise method to
measure functional particles back of our
particles that takes only a day where
the cells are we seed cells in a 24 deep
well format we prepare a serial dilution
of the virus to be tighter infect the
cell for about 16 hours and then the
next day we stain the cells with a anti
JP 64 which is a pack of virus surface
protein that gets display on the cells
and we measure the percent positive
and then based on that we calculate the
tires wonderful thank you
and can we do transient transfection
using explicit to mine enhances and and
feed instead of back to back
I'm not sure I understand the question
very well to be honest you said feet can
it can you repeat the question maybe yes
sorry about that
can we do transient transfection using
excuse me that's perfect
expert set to mine enhancers and feed
instead of back to back
so there's not as part of XPS system we
don't have a feed the back to back is
actually used for the baculovirus tab so
we still use a back back to back yeah
I'm not sure about that question to be
honest
thank you and I want to thank our
audience members for their questions
coming in our next question is how
important is it to code and optimize the
gene for expression in insect cells and
it's a two-part question how well would
a gene optimize for e.coli or heck
Express in this system yeah that's a
great question this is one thing we
haven't tested side by side I mean I've
seen in the literature that there are
some data showing the benefits of color
optimization we have actually expressed
couple of proteins that are typically
expressed in mammalian or equal I system
and have seen a good expression but
again we have not computer side by side
that's a probably good thing to test in
the future
when you compare a different media you
adapted your XP cells to individual
media yeah okay and have you tried to
purify GPCRs for crystallization so this
is one thing that we're working with
cooperator on currently he is to the our
collaborator provided us with the CV to
sequence in we express a protein for him
and he's currently working on trying to
purify it so we don't have the data yet
but it's hopefully coming soon Thank You
Maya and thank you again for our
audience we have wonderful questions
coming in to the cells rice later than
normal in ss9 cells
who sells what all right do this I'm
sorry I just moved it do the cells on it
lice later than normal price of 9 cells
we have not seen that we have seen a
pretty pretty comparable kinetics and
and why think rates between the two
systems
thank you and what is the amount of
popular virus you use for protein
expression we recommend using my 5
meaning 5 viral particles per cell to
get an optimal expression at those
higher densities and Thank You Maya and
how confident are you with your new
system that pure virus is good enough
for protein production how many examples
have you had of different viruses it
unfortunately it does not
um the the member did not yeah we are P
at this point is the system we have
generated viruses for between somewhere
between 5 and 10 different proteins and
we have seen a good consistency in
performance between all of those
proteins thank you and what are what are
the best practices for handling XP s f9
cells 3 questions are the best practices
as I mentioned earlier since those cells
are high density cell line we don't
recommend seeding and packaging those
cells before they got into their optimal
early log phase of about 5 to 10 million
it's very important and then as a
general recommendation we will come up
when handling the cells we recommend a
gentle swirling to mix the cells we
don't recommend a vigorous mixing or
piped ink to ensure the that you have
the best cells for with optimal
performance
and do I really need to either my
baculovirus we do recommend but we
strongly recommend firing the virus to
ensure that you're getting a consistent
result every time because as a
biological system of course sometimes
even though we we have seemed very
consistent back of virus production
Decker virus spiders from transaction to
transaction we're still recommend hiring
and that's why we introduce a newer
faster protein tiring of battle our
soldering methods to help with with that
Thank You Maya and you know what we have
time for a few more questions and I just
want to remind our audience members that
any question is not answered today will
be answered via email the next question
from our audience is how can I tell if
my cells have been efficient efficiently
infected with a virus that's a great
question so I did show that the middle
earlier so here is the typical kinetics
a few of the characteristics we look for
to ensure that the cells are infected
optimally are the viability drop of 16
to 18% of course that that can vary
slightly between different project
classes of proteins but generally with
different proteins that we have
expressed we've seen that range of a 16
to 80% at day 3 as well as the state
cell diameter increase is very important
to note as well since the virus infects
the cells and cell gets will start
producing more protein so diameter is
expected to increase that's another good
indication as well thank you for that
could there be a bigger problem of
proteases due to high cellar
I'm sorry higher cell numbers with XP
affect Emine sf cells upon purification
of protein
that's a great question we usually
recommend adding a protease inhibitor we
have not seen any indication that
there's going to be a problem so we just
purify which is compared purification
comparison from protein expressing the
excess s900 to lower density and
comparison with the XPS F as I show with
the case of security of alkaline
phosphatase and we did not see any
additional degradation or increase
protect ility but again we might do
recommend using a protease inhibitor as
well to eliminate those issues thank you
and Maya do you see increased protein
expression when you use the XPS fcd
medium with sf9
cells
um no we have enough comparison that
particular way we
now I mean I honestly can't cannot
answer them because we haven't compared
them that way but XP sf9 cells are
derived from sf9 self thank you and you
consistently get one times ten nine
titers for Pio virus yes yeah we're
using the suspension protocol if you've
adherence it might be more into the five
ten to the eight range but with using
the suspension protocol we consistently
see over one a nine and p0 we have one
more question coming in do you have any
fluorescent marker fused into dh10 box
cells to monitor by risk production no
we do not we have not done any
improvement on the DHS and bagging the
pieces back or yes thank you actually we
have one more how can I ensure that my
cells are growing optimally so as a as a
quick check we recommend doing a
performing a growth curve since seeding
the cells at 0.5 million and then either
checking the viability and viable cell
density every day or at least checking
at day 5 6 and 7 where the cells would
at about day 6 the cells should reach 18
to 20 million and that's going to ensure
that they're growing they're showing
that the typical kinetics the profile
that we see it also thank you Maya
and thank you to our audience members
the questions continue to come in and we
will continue we have one more question
that's just come in
could you use the XPS fcd media with old
sf9 cells and it's a two-part question
so could we just buy the media and not
new cells
so you probably can but it's probably
going to is going to be associated with
a some level of adaptation as we've seen
with any cell type and switching to a
new media you need to do a certain level
of adaptation to make sure the cells are
adapted to the particular media and can
perform and give you an optimal result
even though we don't guarantee I mean
with it without using the complete XP
system we don't guarantee that you're
going to achieve those highest titers
that we are showing here thank you for
that can the cells be counted with the
countess automatic cell counter we have
not use countess but we're using a
buy-sell out made virus counter so I
believe countess will be also
appropriate metric to use may I thank
you for your presentation today and wow
what a great live participation from our
audience would you like to provide them
with any closing remarks before we close
today yeah I mean thank you very much
for all the questions that was
definitely a great question
Q&A session and as you mentioned any any
further questions can be answered for an
email so if you think of anything else
feel free to reach Thank You Maya and
thank you for your important research
I'd also like to thank Thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May of 2019
please share with your colleagues who
may have missed today's a live event
also stay tuned for our next
presentation optimizing g-protein
coupled receptor expression and
mammalian cells presented by dr. Dean
stas a Pope's post doctoral researcher
from Duke University and dr. Laura
wheeler also a post doctoral researcher
from Duke University you won't want to
miss it that's all for now and thanks
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon
goodbye and have a great day